hello everybody I thought that the
corridor mode wasn't realistic enough so
I decided to amp it up a little bit and
run on a treadmill while I try to
complete my surgery you're gonna see how
it comes Hey feels great
let me tell you okay here we go I'm a
little nervous but here we are corridor
I transplant surgery to show that I
ain't foolin whoo whoo all right let's
do this five miles an hour go okay we
gonna perform an eye transplant hey what
could be so hard why is it be so
difficult why okay oh god okay I got one
this is easy you got tap them by the
head and just got to poop him down to
get his glasses off I'm gonna laugh on
Academy gives glass off there's this
entire thing okay god damn oh I don't
even have a scalpel that wasn't a
scalpel those were to sleep where's a
scalpel this is a drill no no no no no
no no no no how are we all ready 30
seconds in I haven't even done anything
yet let me charge my let me charge my no
no no you get back on there I'll need
you come on what am i running like this
suppose ridiculous running I've ever
done kill me a scalpel give me no that's
a bargain can I get a scalpel I just got
to get this thing off okay that's one
okay
I'm ended up I gotta go up the speed did
I hit it I think I hit it I almost got
to go oh god Mona Mona on him oh no I
made a mistake this is a bad idea
there's a bad idea oh god why am I just
bleeding
why isn't that off yet why isn't it off
yet
where are the goggles off yet I've got a
dying why is he dying okay I saved them
well they're off on the right side but
now for the left side
no how's the humming hock don't have I'm
a hawk
there was a homologue oh I've got
nothing
oh he's coming
give me give me something I just got to
get the goggles on let's got a yellow
zone me right there I got a goggle the
holy ok ok oh we're up on two minutes
already holy hell
southern here we come did I hit them I
think it oka okay I got what I needed
don't go over here Oh give me the eye no
come on give me what are you doing look
that's one polygon orange it's about to
die I'm about to die no no no aah okay
you died no I have to go again huh sorry
really
Brenda my shake-up the recording I'm
still going there's still is go before
now back you're not getting them the
goggles can't get it to cut oh okay all
right look so give me that give me that
give me give me that thing please please
always but it's heart stopped already
no I gotta go date yeah yeah yeah huh I
can't talk to the same time I can't you
he's dead he's dead why is he dead hey
gentlemen
I'm Jeff all right uh it's harder harder
I can't do it the dough are you okay
hybrid oh god I need to get the goggles
huh
I didn't need to get the gun good girl
is a I'll put it up to do the day I got
you know what I got the gun
but here hush oh that's great dollars
get out with my knees as viewing and
zooming on that go is there another
sponge that was good
don't hate you if you like me doing this
just if you did you're a sick bastard
wish if you joined it I want to do more
impossible challenge Let's Plays in the
future so if you have an idea write in
the comments below or if you got another
game that you won't get try while doing
this I know I got it and if your diet is
suffering a blind leave awake don't blow
a great read it so thank y'all felt
wrong see that has all over you next
video bye bye